حذر رئيس ارمينيا من تحول منطقه القوقاز
الى مشكله معقده اذا لم يتدخل المجتمع
الدولي لايقاف الحرب في اقليم كارباخ
مؤكدا ان بلاده غير راغبه في التصعيد
وتقبل الوساطه الروسيه يتزامن هذا مع
احتدام المعارك في كارباخ واعلان اذربيجان
تحقيق تقدم في جبهات
القتال
اهلا بكم كان هذا خبر حلقتنا ونناقش فيما
وراءه ما امكانيه التجاوب مع دعوات وقف
القتال بين ارمينيا واذربيجان في الظروف
الراهنه وما تداعيات اتساع هذا الصراع على
الوضع في منطقه القوقاز في ضوء مواقف
القوه الاقليميه والدوليه في هذه
[موسيقى]
الازمه
اعترف الرئيس الارميني ارمين سركسيان
بوجود مقاتلين اجانب من الارمن يقاتلون
الى جانب القوات الارمينيه في النزاع
الدائري مع اذربيجان وفي حديث خاص مع
الجزيره اتهم تركيا بالتدخل المباشر في
القتال الى جانب اذربيجان وحذر الرئيس
الارميني من تحول منطقه القوقاز الى ما
وصفها بسوريا اخرى بسبب النزاع الدائر في
اقليم كارباخ واكد ارمين سركيسيان ان
ارمينيا ترحب بالوساطه الروسيه في هذه
الازمه كما تحاول احتواء الصراع في حدوده
الحاليه نحن لا نريد التصعيد وهناك امر
واضح نحن لا نريد تصعيد هذا الصراع بين
جمهوريه ن جورنو كارباخ واذربيجان الى
مستويات اعلى ولهذا السبب انت قلت ايضا
بانني احذر بانه ان ما كان هذا الصراع سي
يزداد مستواه فان القوقاز سوف تصبح سوريا
اخرى ولن يساعدنا احد في المنطقه لحل هذا
الصراع لذلك نحاول احتواء هذا الصراع في
حدوده
الحاليه هل ارمينيا تقبل الوساطه الروسيه
اذا ما ابتدات بذلك الجواب هو مبدئيا نعم
ولكن الوساطه هي عمليه مستمره وتبدا بوسطا
محددين وارتباطات بين الساسه والعسكريين
وهكذا ولكن هذه العمليه لم تبدا بعد نعم
اذا نحن مستعدون للوساطه وخاصه من قبل
روسيا اذا ما كانت هذه الوساطه سوف يتم
تنظيمها هذا وكان رئيس اذربيجان الهام
عليف قال ان الشرط الوحيد لوقف المعارك مع
ارمينيا في اقليم كارباخ المتنازع عليه هو
انسحاب كامل وانسحاب كامل وغير مشروط ودون
اخير للقوات المدعومه من يريفان في
المنطقه واعلن عليف ان قواته حررت نقاطا
استراتيجيه من قبضه ما وصفه بالاحتلال
واكد انه لا يمكن لاحد ان يخرج بلاده من
تلك الاراضي بعد الان وقال ان ذلك تحقق
بفضل ما وصفها بالعمليات العسكريه الناجحه
التي تعهد
بمواصلة وهي بصدد فعل ذلك
وستفعل لمناقشه هذا الملف المتفاقم ينضم
الينا من يريفان هايك كون جوريان عضو
البرلمان الارميني ومن نيويورك الدكتور
عبد الحميد صيام الخبير في شؤون الامم
المتحده ومن باكو عبر الهاتف سيفيل ميكوفا
عضو البرلمان الاذربيجاني اهلا بضيوفي
الكرام وابدا بضيفي من ريبان السيد هايك
كون جوريان
ل فهم ما قيل وما قاله الرئيس الارميني
للجزيره بان ارمينيا مستعده لتقبل الوساطه
الروسيه لكن وفق اي منظور بالنسبه للجانب
الارميني ليدخل في مفاوضات حقيقيه من اجل
ايجاد حل هذه
الازمه
بدايه ينبغ ان اقول ان
ارمينيا دائما ملتزمه بالمفاوضات السلميه
ونعتقد انه ليس هناك بديل عن الحل السلمي
لهذا النزاع حول ناغورني كارباخ لكن لسوء
الحظ لعشرات
السنين كنا نشهد
الاذربيجاني ا
يتبنون منطقا حربيا عسكريا
وتهديدات لايجاد حل حل عسكر لهذا
النزاع
اذربيجان بدات عده س مرات ال وهو
مثال
ل اللهجه
العدائيه والهجوميه من القياده
الاذربيجانيه ولسوء الحظ
فاننا نرى المجتمع الدولي يدعو الى وقف
فوري لاطلاق النار ويدعو جميع الاطراف
لاستئناف المفاوضات من اجل حل سلمي واود
ان اكرر ان موقفنا هو لص اننا جاهزون للحل
السلمي لكننا متاكد من ان ذ
مهم
جدا حتى تتوفر الاجواء
المناسبه والبيئه المناسبه
لسلام وعندما نواجه المقصود وابقى معك سيد
هايك ما المقصود بالبيئه المناسبه يعني ما
الشرط يعني هل فقط على الوضع الحالي يكفي
وقف اطلاق النار للدخول في
المفاوضات
نحن نفهم الان ان
اذربيجان تتحدث وتضع شروطا
مسبقه و وهي شروط من جانب واحد
وانهم ليسوا مستعدين لوقف نار وقف فوري
لاطلاق النار بينما نحن مستعدون للحل
السلمي لكن حظ نرى ان اذربيجان ولكن تركيا
ايضا يحاول ان يزعزع استقرار منطقه وان
يجدوا حل حلا عسكريا لهذا النزاع اذا انا
متاكد واعتقد ان هذا هذه احدى اكبر
العقبات ل امام المفاوضات ولحل السلمي
ولذلك ادع سوف نناقش هذه المساله ولكن فقط
اردنا ان نبدا
بمساله النيه في وقف اطلاق النار والدخول
بشكل او باخر قبول الوساطات الدوليه لاجل
البحث عن حل وهنا اسال ضيفي من باكو السيد
ميكايل لوفا ايضا عن ما القرار في باكو
فيما يتعلق بالدعوات لوقف اطلاق النار
الرئيس عليف قال سوف نبقى على ما حققناه
الان وبالتالي هل هناك شروط من قبل باكو
لوقف اطلاق النارمن ثم قبول اي وساطه او
الدخول في
التفاوض
اولا اريد
ان اسال ماذا يفعل
الجنود
الارميني في ارض اذربيجانيه هذه ارض معترف
بها دوليا على انها ارض
اذربيجانيه تم احتلالها و مضى على هذا
الاحتلال 30 عاما وايضا ال الدوليه
وقرارات مجلس الامن تطالب ارمينيا بسحب
قواتها من هذا الاحتلال غير الشرعي لكن
حتى الان لم نتوصل الى نتيجه
وارمينيا الان خرقت كل الخطوط الحمراء
وايضا هم يطلبون وقفا لاطلاق النار
الان نحن ضحايا لغياب وقف اطلاق الن نار
لمده 30 عاما وغيابهم عن طاوله المفاوضات
30 عاما طالبنا بها لكن ماذا كانت النتيجه
لم تثمر تلك المفاوضات عن ايه نتائج وال
كل ما انبثق عن تلك المفاوضات تم تدميره
من خلال الاعمال
الاستفزازيه لارمينيا التي ارتكبوها امام
انظار المجتمع الدولي وقد اخترقوا اخر
خرقوا اخر هدنه ووقف اطلاق النار وقاموا
بشن هذه الهجمات على
اذربيجان الجيش الاذربيجاني رد و على هذه
الهجمات نعم نحن بلد محب للسلام ويمكن ان
نعود الى مفاوضات السلام لكن لدينا شرط
واحد وهو ان قوات الاحتلال ين يجب ان
تنسحب من الارض الاذربيجانيه بعد ذلك نمكن
ان نتحدث عن خطوات اخر مفاوضات
سلام لنبدا او لنعود للخطوه الاولى سيده
سل وابقى معك ما تعليقكم على ما صرح به
الرئيس الارميني للجزيره بان
ارمينيا غير راغبه في التصعيد عفوا سيده س
غير راغبه في التصعيد فيما يتعلق بهذه
الازمه اوكي
ثم الدخول او القبول بالوساطه الروسيه
ماذا عن هذه الخطوه سيده
سيفيل طيب ساعود الى ضيفتي بقط حلما
نتجاوز مساله التواصل معها هاتفيه لاسال
ضيفي الدكتور عبد الحميد الصيام فيما
يتعلق الان
ب مساله معقده جدا عندما يتعلق الامر
بالصراع التاريخي بين اذربيجان وارمينيا
تعقيد يعني معقد في داخله بين البلدين
معقد في اقليمه ومعقد دوليا ماذا تستطيع
الامم المتحده فيما يتعلق بالوضع الحالي
بين البلدين فيما يتعلق بهذا
الاقليم شكرا اخي عبد القادر هذه قضيه يجب
ان نعود الى جذورها فتجمد الصراع لا حله
ما قام به المجتمع الدولي عام
1993 هو بتجميد الصراع هناك اربعه قرارات
اعتمدها مجلس الامن القرار 822 في ابريل
1993 وقرار 854 وقرار
874 وقرار
884 بتاريخ في نوفمبر
1993 هذه القرارات هي التي تضع الاسس
الصحيحه للحل لانها تطالب المع اعتدي بوقف
اعتدائه
وبالانجليزي من 20% من اراضي اذربيجان
محتله ناغورنو كارباخ يشكل احد 11% فقط و
99% احتلت من اراضي اذربيجان خلال الحروب
يعني اضافه الى ناغورنو كارباخ هناك سبعه
مناطق محتله تشكل 99% من اراضي اذربيجان
قرارات مجلس الامن واضحه تطالب بالانسحاب
تطالب باعاده المهجرين تطالب بوقف اطلاق
النار والعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات ما
عملته مجموعه منسك التي
اي تكون من روسيا والولايات المتحده
وفرنسا هو تجميد الصراع لم يق لم يقدموا
اي شيء لحل هذا النزاع منذ عام 93 الى
اليوم عندما بدات ارمينيا تبني جيشها
بمساعده روسيا كانت في وضع قوي في وجود
قوات روسيه
تساعدها في هذه السنوات قامت اذربيجان
ببناء جيشها وتدريبه وتسليحه واصبحت
مستعده للعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات حول
الانسحاب فقط هناك ضغط شعبي هناك مظاهرات
خرجت في باكو في يوليو هذا العام تطالب
الرئيس علي ييف بتجنيد الشعب والعوده الى
القتال لان هذه اراضي محتله لهم هي هم
يملكونها دون ان نرى هذه الصوره لا تستطيع
لا الامم المتحده ولا مجموعه منسك ولا
منظمه الامن والتعاون الاوروبي بحل هذه
القضيه طيب هذا وقد اصدر رؤساء الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه دونالد ترامب وروسيا
فلاديمير بوتين وفرنسا ايمانويل ماكرون
بيانا بشان صراع في كارباخ ندد القاده
الثلاثه فيه بالتصعيد العنيف في المنطقه
واعربوا عن اسفهم لسقوط عدد من ضحاياها
ودعى القاده الى الوقف الفوري لاطلاق
النار بين قوات الجانبين والعوده فورا الى
الحوار دون شروط مسبقه وعلى اساس حسن
النيه تحت اشراف الدول
الثلاث هذا وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه ان
الوزيرين الروسي سيرجي لافروف والتركي
مولوت شاوش اغلو اكد استعداد بلديهما
للتنسيق العمل من اجل تحقيق استقرار
الاوضاع في كارباخ واعاده طرفي الصراع في
لله التفاوض واعرب عن قلقهما ازاء التصعيد
في هذه المنطقه في ضوء التفاعلات الدوليه
مع تطورات الصراع بين ارمينيا واذربيجان
نسال عن تداعيات استمراره خاصه على منطقه
القوقاز وهنا اسال ضيفي من يرفان السيد
هايك فيما يتعلق بهذا التطور هذا التصريح
الروسي التركي بالرغبه في وقف التصعيد
وجلوس الطرفين من اجل ايجاد حل وبالتالي
ما تعليقك على هذا المسعى او التصريحات
التركيه روسيه سيد
هايك
اليوم رساء ثلاث
بلدان الولايات المتحده وفرنسا و روسيا
دعوا الى وقف فوري لاطلاق النار
ى استئناف في المفاوضات بدون شروط
مسبقه ولكن نرى ان الجانب
الاذربيجاني يضع ذلك الشرط غير المقبول
وغير
المنطقي ولا معنى
له وبالنسبه
للمفاوضات
وللسلام هناك عقبات كثيره واحدى هذه
العقبات هو تدخل التركي في
النزاع لدينا تقارير
لها مصداقيه من وسائل اعلام
دوليه موثوقه تقول ان
تركيا
تستخدم مقاتلين اجانب من سوريا للقتال في
ناغورنو كارباخ واليوم تركيا واذربيجان
يقاتلان ليس فقطار سيد هايك عضر المقاطعه
ولكن ماذا ايضا عن اعتراف الرئيس
الرئيس الارميني بان كل الارمن في العالم
مدعوون وايضا جزء منهم موجود للقتال الى
جانب ارمينيا ماذا ايضا عن هذا
البعد نعم هناك مقاتلون اجانب في
اذربيجان وانا
ذكرت تحدثت عن التقارير من الجارد والبي
بي سي ورويترز ان
تركيا انتدبت مقاتلين من سوريا وارسلته
الى اذربيجان لا عفوا ربما ربما لم يسك
سؤالي بشكل جيد سيد هايك فقط اعيد صياغه
سؤال ربما العيب في الصياغه هنا اتكلم عن
ما اعترف به السيد سركسيان الرئيس
الارميني بان الارمن في كل دول العالم
وجزء منهم موجود الان ليقاتل الى جانب
ارمينيا في اذربيجان اليس هؤلا ايضا عناصر
اجنبيه فقط يكفي بانهم من اصول ارمينيه
حتى يقاتلوا في هذه
الحرب الارمني في ارمينيا هم ارمون
مواطنون ارماني ومن ناجورنو كارباخ بطبيعه
الحال هم
جاهزون الرئيس تكلم من خارج ارمينيا من
خارج
ارمينيا
لا
لا انا لست
متاكدا ربما انه كان هناك سوء
فهم لم يكن هناك
اي قوات من خارج
ارمينيا لان مواطنين ارمني ومن ناجورنو
كارباخ يدافعون عن انفسهم امام هذا
الاعتداء
من اذربيجان وتركيا على كل سيد هايك تصريح
الرئيس الارميني سيبث في قناه الجزيره في
لقائه مع الجزيره وفيه يقول بوجود ويعتر
بوجود مقاتلين اجانب من الارمن يقاتلون
الى جانب القوات الارمينيه في النزاع
الدائر مع اذربيجان هذا التصريح موجود
معنا في الجزيره للرئيس ارمين سركسيان
ادلى به للجزيره وهنا اسال ضيفتي من باكو
والسيده
سيفيل يالوفا الرئيس الارمني ايضا يحذر من
ان هذا الصراع ان لم يتم تداركه فسيصبح
سوريا ثانيه في هذه المنطقه الحساسه هل
انتم هل ماذا عن هذا التوصيف بدايه وهل
انتم مستعدون لهذه التداعيات التي يحذر
منها الرئيس
الارميني لا اتفق مع هذا التوصيف ابدا لان
اذربيجان سوف تحرر هذه لانها ارضنا ارض
اذربيجان والسلام سيحل في جنوب القوقاز
واذربيجان حالها حال البلدان الاخرى سوف
تساهم في تعزيز الامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه وسوف نفعل كل ما بقدرتنا لضمان
ذلك لاننا على مدى 30 عاما ارمينيا دمرت
امن المنطقه برمتها وقد ان الاوان لكي
نخضع حدا لهذه النشاطات غير المشروعه التي
قامت بها ارمينيا وذبح الاذربيجاني وهذه
حقائق تاريخيه لا يمكن انكارها لان
ارمينيا ارتكبت جرائم مريعه على هذه الارض
وايضا الان ارمينيا
تدعو
العائلات ومن من مناطق اخرى ليستو هذه
الارض بشكل غير مشروع وقبل يومين او ثلاثه
من هذا الهجوم قام ما يسمى برئيس جمهوريه
نورنو كارباخ قال بان بامكان العائلات
والتي دعاها وهي عائلات
ارمينيه من خارج المنطقه من مدن وبلدان
اخرى لياتوا ليستقروا في منطقه ناغورنو
كارباخ هذا امر يتنافى مع القانون الدولي
ومعاهدات جنيف خاصه اتفاقيه جنيف الخامسه
والهم يريدون استفزاز المنطقه لتدخل في
حاله من الحرب ويريدون توريط بلدان اخرى
في هذا ال ولكن سيده سيفيل ما الذي يمنع
من ذلك في ملف حساس كملف كارباخ في ملف
فيه لاعبين كثر ولاعبين كبار من العالم
اذا ما الذي يمنع ان يتطور الى حرب تتجاوز
الحدود نعم كما قلنا نحن من
قبل الشرط الوحيد الذي نحن نريد تطبيقه هو
انسحاب القوات ارمانيه من ارضنا
والذين جاؤوا من مناطق وبلدان اخرى يجب ان
يعودوا الى مناطقهم لكي يحل السلام والا
فان السلام مهدد في هذه المنطقه ككل ولن
نحصل على ايه نتائج مثمره كنتيجه
لاي جهد على بلدان المنطقه الاخرى ان تعمل
من اجل تحقيق ذلك وحمايه سلامه اراضي
اذربيجان وتضمن تطبيق القرارات التي صدرت
عن الامم المتحده وان ايضا تلتزم
بالمواثيق
الدوليه هذه الحاله اسال ضيفي من نيويورك
الدكتور عبد الحميد صيام دكتور عبد الحميد
هل التصريحات الدوليه حتى الان خاصه من
الاطراف المباشره سواء من الجانب الروسي
او الجانب التركي او التصريحات الامريكيه
او الفرنسيه ا كافيه لطمانه بان هذا الملف
لن يتسع ام ان خلف الاكمه ما
خلفها يعني اعتقد ان اعضاء مجلس الامن
يشعرون الان بان الامور بدات تنزلق الى
حرب شامله وكان هناك اجتماع مغلق يوم
الثلاثاء وصدر او عناصر بيان صحفي عن مجلس
الامن تشير الى هذه الحقيقه وضروره وقف
اطلاق النار
اذا لم يكن هناك اشتباكات يبقى مجلس الامن
ساكتا ويبقى المجتمع الدولي صامط هذه قضيه
قديمه اهملت داخل مجلس الامن لانه لم يكن
هناك دماء تسيل الان عندما راوا ان هناك
اشتباكات وبدات الامور تتفاقم
يحزمون امرهم ويعقدون اجتماعا ثم يضعون
عناصر لحل سياسي يقوم على وقف اطلاق النار
وتخفيف التصعيد والعوده الى المفاوضات
وهذا ديدن المجتمع الدولي عندما لا يكون
هناك اشتباكات تبقى الامور كما هي تهمل
القضيه رغم انها لم تحل وهذا مثلا ما يجري
في كشمير عندما يبدا النزاع و تبدا الدماء
تسيل وتبدا الاشتباكات يعودون الى القضيه
يعني اهملت قضيه كشمير اكثر
من 50 سنه وعادت السنه الماضيه الى مجلس
الامن وقضيه ناغورنو كارباخ اهملت منذ عام
93 رغم انه كان هناك اشتباكات عام 2016
و207 وفي يوليو الماضي كان هناك اشتباكات
ولم يتحرك مجلس الامن الان يتحرك لانه بدا
يعرف ان الظلم الذي وقع في عام
1993 وطالب مجلس الامن حرفيا بالانسحاب من
مد من منطقه زنجلان ومدينه جورديس التي
احتلتها ارمينيا وص صوص عليها حرفيا في
قرار
884 الصادر في نوفمبر
1993 لم تحرك المجتمع الدولي وا اذربيجان
قالت ان مجموعه منسك ليست عادله ليست
محايده روسيا اقرب الى ارمينيا وفرنسا
اقرب الى ارمينيا وحتى الولايات المتحده
لم تاخذ موقفا حاسما لذلك الان هناك فرصه
حقيقيه لان اذربيجان الان تشعر بالقوه
تستطيع ان تسترد بعض المناطق المحتله
وبتالي سنرى حركه دبلوماسيه سلق الامر بان
الاطراف الداعمه لهذا الطرف او ذاك اطراف
قويه ولها كلمتها في مجلس الامن هل عوده
الملف مره اخرى الى مجلس الامن بسخونته قد
يتغير هذه المره حتى في ظل المعطيات
الدوليه
المعروفه نعم انا اعتقد ان هناك تغييرات
حقيقيه الان لان موازين القوى بدات تتغير
يعني
اذربيجان وللعلم انا زرت اذربيجان عام
2016 وجدت ان هذه قضيه راي عام لا خلاف
عليه
وكل يقول بان ما اخذ بالقوه لا يسترد
بالقوه الان هناك فرصه حقيقيه لحل هذه
الازمه من نيويورك الدكتور عبد الحميد
صيام الخبير في شؤون الامم المتحده شكرا
جزيلا لك وكذلك لضيف من يرفان هايك كون
جوريان عضو البرلمان الارميني من وكذلك
لضيف من باكو سيفيل السيده سيفيل مكيا
لوفا عضو البرلمان
الاذربيجاني بذا نصل الى ختام هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله
في قراءه جديده في ما وراء خبر جديد الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء